[Music]
that was how 43 year old New Yorker Eric
garner died on July 17th after police
put in in what looks like a trophy
police say Garner was on the sidewalk
illegally selling cigarettes witnesses
say he was actually trying to break up a
fight
the thousands more said that's just not
the point
[Music]
the hashtags Eric garner justice for
Eric garner and r.i.p Eric garner have
been used to express disgust and anger
with folks accusing police of killing
yet another unarmed african-american man
Steve Marmol tweeted just make this
trend
hashtag justice for Eric garner and from
Linda Sarsour there are six children in
Staten Island sleeping tonight without
their dad Eric Garner's family deserves
justice Garner's Widow and other family
members went to rallies in Harlem and
Staten Island on July 19 people
everywhere have condemned doctors
Garner's death but the root problem of
police brutality targeting communities
of color Tim Moore said what the NYPD
did to Eric garner illustrates why black
men live in here daily and DJ Rob Swift
admitted when I see a cop walking
towards me on the sidewalk I cross over
to the other side of the street
others demanded accountability the most
horrific thing I've seen in a very long
time Eric garner r.i.p i hope every cop
who participated gets life in prison so
far the cop who put Eric garner in the
alleged chokehold a move that's illegal
was stripped of his gun and badge but is
still at work on desk duty an
investigation is underway there's
actually a long list of controversial
killings that have led to little if any
jail time
the NYPD officer who shot and killed
unarmed Ramarley Graham in his own
apartment in 2012 was originally charged
with manslaughter but the case was later
dropped the transit officer who killed
unarmed Oscar Grant at a train station
in Oakland California ended up serving
just a little more than a year of
time for involuntary manslaughter and
the police who fired 50 bullets at Sean
Bell and two other unarmed men in Queens
back in 2006 all got off scot-free on
Instagram I am Queen 31 wrote rest in
peace Eric garner Sean Bell Trayvon
Martin batts just to name a few the list
goes on
the police confrontation with Eric
garner was caught on video but what
about all the others that aren't are you
fed up with police brutality join the
hashtag Eric garner if so and let us
know what you think by tweeting us at H
a plus
[Music]